Trascrizione: Esraa Hamza
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Partirò da un tram.
Mi attaccherò a un tram
per parlarvi di verità.
Partirò da un tram come fa,
nel libro "Esercizi di stile", Queneau.
Parte proprio da un fatto banalissimo:
una persona che sale su un tram a cavalli,
viene spintonato,
vede una persona che poi rincontra
in una stazione, tempo dopo.
Queneau usa questa immagine
per spiegarci che la verità è complessa,
che di quel fatto banalissimo
ci sono 99 persone che leggono
una realtà diversa.
In guerra, è ancor più complesso.
In guerra, la verità
è ancora più una missione impossibile.
In guerra, la verità è la prima vittima.
Perché?
Perché in guerra,
raramente dici ciò che farai.
Vi ricordate i nostri nonni?
"Taci che il nemico ti ascolta"
In guerra, tendenzialmente,
neghi le brutte notizie,
ciò che realmente succede, le perdite.
In guerra, tendenzialmente,
esalti ciò che non succede:
le vittorie, anche se non ci sono.
E la propaganda, in guerra,
serve internamente
a far stringere la popolazione
attorno alla bandiera,
ed esternamente a indebolire,
sfiancare gli avversari
anche con le menzogne:
le  "nobili menzogne", diceva Platone.
Quante ne abbiamo viste, nella Storia,
di menzogne più o meno nobili?
Agosto 1964, golfo del Tonchino,
al largo del Vietnam.
Gli USA denunciano gli attacchi
di navi nord-vietnamite
a un loro cacciatorpediniere.
Dopo cinque giorni,
il Presidente Johnson
ottiene dal Congresso
l'autorizzazione ad attaccare
il Vietnam del Nord.
Solo 18 anni dopo si riuscì a dimostrare
come quell'episodio
non fosse mai avvenuto,
a sette anni dalla fine della guerra.
Ma veniamo a qualcosa
di più vicino a noi, al 2003.
5 febbraio: Colin Powell,
Segretario di stato di Bush,
al Consiglio di Sicurezza dell'ONU
mostra una fiala
che contiene polvere bianca.
L'Iraq di Saddam, dice Powell al mondo,
sta sviluppando armi
di distruzione di massa.
Due settimane dopo,
inizia l'invasione dell'Iraq.
Scopriremo che gli USA avevano già preso
la decisione di invadere l'Iraq
prima delle prove - false - all'ONU,
e che fossero false lo confessò, poi,
lo stesso Powell nel 2016.
Potrei continuare,
se non avessi 12 minuti,
con altri casi di menzogne simili
di russi, cinesi, coreani, chi vogliamo.
In questa guerra,
la guerra di questi mesi,
la verità è ancor più complessa,
ancora più una missione impossibile.
Perché questa guerra
è diversa dalle precedenti
per almeno tre motivi.
È più vicina:
e in quanto più vicina a noi,
mette più in gioco le emozioni,
e le emozioni sono un ostacolo
importante per la verità.
Vicina non solo geograficamente,
perché i suoi due attori ci sono vicini -
i russi da decenni,
con i loro yacht in Costa Smeralda,
ma anche banalmente alle terme,
al tavolo a fianco al nostro,
o a fare shopping per le vie di Milano.
Badanti e domestiche ucraine,
e non ci sono solo badanti
e domestiche ucraine,
da anni nelle nostre famiglie,
con i nostri nonni,
un prezioso e solido aiuto
della nostra vita di tutti i giorni.
Vivono con noi, sono vicini a noi;
e non era così con la Siria,
con l'Afghanistan,
neppure con i Balcani,
geograficamente così vicini a noi.
Questa guerra è più vicina a noi
anche perché nelle TV,
nei nostri parlamenti,
Zelensky si rivolge a noi
direttamente ogni giorno.
Non c'è mai stato un presidente
di un paese in guerra
così attivo nella comunicazione.
E Zelensky è efficace:
era un attore, sa quali corde toccare.
Questa guerra è più vicina sempre,
perché Zelensky, con il suo uso continuo
di Telegram e dei social,
ha reso questo conflitto
la guerra più social,
e più in tempo reale, di tutti i tempi.
E le fake news, che ci siamo
abituati a conoscere -
si spera anche a riconoscere,
negli ultimi anni -
entrano in questa guerra,
che vede un'esplosione dei social,
e si propagano con ancor più facilità,
complice il nevrotico
inseguimento della notizia.
E così, anche un TG serio
presenta le immagini di una pioggia
di missili che cade sull'Ucraina,
non accorgendosi che si tratta
di un filmato di un videogame,
"War Thunder".
Questa guerra è diversa dalle altre,
proprio perché è molto social.
E come sempre avviene con i social,
siamo sommersi da informazioni micro
e rischiamo di perdere di vista il macro.
Ogni giorno, i giornali riportano, live,
centinaia di notizie
e dichiarazioni dei protagonisti,
minuto per minuto.
Ogni trasmissione -
quante ne avete viste? -
hanno quattro o cinque inviati
che in posti diversi
dell'Ucraina ci raccontano -
nei primi giorni ci raccontavano il micro
di cosa vedevano nella loro via,
nel loro rifugio, in fondo alla strada,
e noi eravamo sommersi.
Si ripropone il dramma
della nostra società di Internet:
abbiamo accesso a un'enorme
quantità di notizie micro,
ma a volte non riusciamo
a mettere insieme il quadro macro.
Più informazione, lo sappiamo,
non necessariamente
significa più comprensione.
Infine, questa guerra è diversa
perché è più che mai la prova provata
di ciò che Tucidide,
che di guerra se ne intendeva,
scriveva nel V secolo a.C.
"Durante il conflitto,
i contendenti cambiarono -
parlava del Peloponneso - a piacimento
il significato consueto delle parole
in rapporto ai fatti."
Noi parliamo in questa guerra
di "crimini di guerra",
di "escalation della guerra",
di rischi di guerra nucleare,
mentre Mosca continua a chiamarla
"operazione speciale".
Ma la distorsione delle parole
non è solo del Cremlino:
Kiev, e tutti noi, abbiamo parlato
di "evacuazione" dei soldati
dall'acciaieria.
E non di "resa",
quando è ovvio che si è trattato
di entrambe le cose.
È un'evacuazione,
perché si sono spostate
delle persone in pericolo
da un posto all'altro;
ma è anche una resa,
perché hanno smesso di combattere
e sono tutt'oggi prigionieri dei russi.
Pensateci:
persino un termine che ha un preciso
significato giuridico e storico,
"genocidio",
viene citato in questa guerra
con una frequenza mai vista prima,
e da entrambe le parti.
Ha iniziato Putin,
ripetendo in ogni occasione
che la Russia è in Ucraina
per evitare il genocidio
dei filorussi nel Donbass.
Ma da qualche settimana,
anche Zelensky ripete
che nel Donbass c'è un'ovvia politica
di genocidio da parte della Russia.
Ok.
La verità è la prima vittima della guerra.
La verità è una missione
impossibile, in questa guerra,
con le emozioni, così presenti
per la vicinanza, per l'eccesso
di informazioni micro,
per le parole che traggono in inganno.
Ma alla fine della giornata,
c'è un paese invasore, un paese invaso.
C'è un paese distrutto,
un paese che lo distrugge.
Un paese da cui fuggono cinque milioni
di donne, bambini e anziani,
e uno che ne provoca la fuga.
Non ha troppo senso, a questo punto,
allargare lo zoom al 2014,
e alle colpe ucraine e europee
per la mancata attuazione
degli accordi di Minsk.
Perché anche nel 2014, alla fine,
era stata un'invasione,
anche se più mascherata e meno plateale.
Non ha senso ricordare i fasti
dell'Impero sovietico,
o dell'Impero russo.
Ma la verità è anche,
come dice Papa Francesco,
che la guerra distrugge
sia gli sconfitti che i vincitori,
chi è invaso come chi invade.
Serve trovare una via d'uscita,
serve realismo da entrambe le parti.
E senza scandalizzarsi,
se si invoca appunto realismo
sia agli ucraini che ai russi.
Un po' di realismo,
un pizzico di creatività,
e di idealismo quanto basta,
sono gli ingredienti irrinunciabili
per mettere la parola fine
a questa guerra.
Questi ingredienti - realismo,
creatività e idealismo -
dovrebbero essere gli strumenti di lavoro
anche per chi, come me, fa l'analista,
gli apprendisti Burioni della guerra.
Dovremmo cercare,
in questo quadro così complesso,
da capire di trasmettere, di esercitare,
pur con tutti i nostri limiti
di emozioni e conoscenza,
di trasmettere realismo,
creatività, idealismo;
ma con un realismo che non diventi
necessariamente cinismo,
e con una creatività e un idealismo
che non si trasformino
in una favola irrealizzabile.
È un impegno di moderazione,
di toni misurati,
di denunciare quando qualcosa non torna,
qualcosa non quadra
nelle notizie che riceviamo.
Incrociamo le dita.
(Applausi)